(clicks)
- Yeah lets.
- You guys wanna take some
questions from the crowd?
- Let's do it.
- That'd be awesome.
- Lets do questions
from the crowd.
- We have a microphone here.
We have a microphone back there.
There's a person standing
there with the microphone
and if you'd like to
ask a question just go
- To the microphone.
- Line up way, way,
way, back there.
- Alright.
- That's a great
place to put the mic.
We can't see you.
- Alright, okay.
- We cannot see.
- Are you lining up for
questions or just leaving?
- Move that forward
a little bit.
- Yeah.
- Hi back there.
Do you have a question
for the Workaholics?
- Yeah.
I was wondering how you guys
can keep a straight face
while you guys are improving
like throughout the show,
'cause on the drunkumentary
you guys said that like
80% is just improv?
- Uh we were drunk
when we said 80%
- 36,
- 36.
- Yeah, it's 36% improv.
- But you watched the
Drunkmentary and that's insane.
- That's really cool.
- That is cool.
- That's cool.
That is totally incoherent.
The Drunkmentary was a, we
thought it'd be a great idea
to just get black out
drunk and do the commentary
for our show.
(audience laughs)
And then by episode like three
we were like 11 beers deep.
- Ma!
- A lot of.
- And it's just us just farting.
- A lot of farting.
- [Kyle] Tons of farting.
- That's where that went.
(burps)
- Ew.
- I think we take a
- The girls liked that.
- Yeah.
- Cool chicks.
- He bear within Anders.
- Cool fans alright.
(audience laughs)
Very cool.
- [Tom] Are any of you
guys drunk right now?
- Uh, #stilldrunk.
- #stilldrunk.
- Okay.
- Do you tweet?
- [Tom] Okay, who else
has got a question?
- We keep straight faces
because we're professionals
to answer the question.
- Yeah man it's called acting.
- We're professional actors.
- That's how.
- It's acting.
- Look how straight faced
we can be right now.
Alright, go.
- Hey guys,
- [Tom] Go ahead
with your question.
- I'm just wondering when's
the next wizard album?
- What's that?
- Oh.
- Well.
- Wizards.
- I'll let the
professor take that one.
- Uh we're starting to
compile some beats right now
so I mean stay tuned, once
we get a little bit of time
in the studio I think we'll
drop it as soon as we can.
(laughs)
- In six months.
- Yeah.
- In six month.
- Say uh yeah, six months man.
- Six months to four
years, somewhere in there.
- Yeah.
- Somewhere in between that.
- You know it's like
spaghetti incident or whatever
Guns 'n Roses are calling it.
- We have to get
those dudes out here,
and that's kind of a pain.
- Right, they're
in another realm.
- We have to summon
them, it's a.
- For those of you who
don't know we have a,
or we don't have actually.
- Adam!
- We have a portal in our home,
opened up from another realm
and four wizards who
look very similar to us,
coincidentally.
- Yeah.
- Came out of the portal
and they just happened
to be gangster rapping wizards.
- Yes.
- And
- yeah.
- They have an album on iTunes
that you could purchase,
Purple Magic, check it out.
- Yeah, it's 14 tracks for
9.99 that sounds like a deal.
- Whoa.
- Yeah, that's a deal.
- It's a hell of a deal.
- Whoa.
- So I don't know.
- There's a couple music
videos on Youtube too.
You should check it
out 'cause you all know
what Youtube is now.
- Yeah, Pdub, Pdub, Pdub, Pdub.
- Nobody knows what Youtube is?
- [Tom] You guys have
heard of Youtube right?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- [Tom] Okay, who
else has a question?
Do you have a question?
- Tyedye dog.
- [Tom] Go ahead, what's
your question sir?
- Where, where's Chris at?
- [Tom] And why are you so
much louder than everyone else?
- What happened?
- Yeah what happened?
- I have a little
more confidence maybe.
- Oh nice.
- Oh!
Next question!
- [Blake] Fire!
- [Anders] Next question please!
- You know what that means?
- Tuck your confidence back
in your fly and walk away.
- Chris who, Delia?
- Are you talking
about Chris Delia sir?
- Or Criss Angel?
- Criss Angel?
He's in Vegas.
Baby.
- Criss Angel, we
don't know him.
- We don't know Criss
Angel, I don't know.
- We would like
for him to be here,
if was a fan or if.
- We can't hand with
anybody that cut though.
- Yeah, he's too ripped for us.
- You know,
- Very ripped.
- Makes us feel flabby.
- A nice amount of squoosh.
- Alright Gilligan,
what's your question?
- Dude those that fit.
- [Blake] Oh yeah.
- Okay, so Blake you
went on Loiter Squad
for a couple episodes,
- Yeah.
- [Questioner] I was wondering,
- All right yeah.
- If you would have some
more of the Odd Future Crew
come on Workaholics
maybe for next season.
Do you think that you
might see that happening?
- I would never rule that out,
we had Taco on the
show very briefly
in the high school
episode, but uh.
- We had Tyler too, but.
- Yeah he was there.
- He got cut out.
- He was in the front yard.
- But you totally
can't see him at all.
- [Blake] Yeah, yeah,
- [Anders] Yup.
- But yeah, no, I
wouldn't be opposed to it
those guys are pretty nice.
They're just a little,
they're hard to wrangle.
- Mmmhmm.
- Yeah.
- Slippery.
- Fuckers.
- Rap stars.
- Is that okay with you?
(audience laughs)
- Great.
- Yeah, well, maybe.
- Maybe yeah.
Yeah maybe.
- Gilligan.
- Is this the dumbest
panel all day?
It has to be right?
- Yeah.
- I feel like other
people were like giving
like you guys information
and we're like wawa.
- Tight butt hole.
- All of our answers are
like, I don't know, maybe,
I don't know.
- We'll see.
- Why are you asking us?
- Yeah we don't know.
- Well we're having fun.
- We're having fun.
- yeah.
- We're having a good time.
- Is everyone having fun here?
- Come on guys!
(cheers and applause)
- Yes.
- Come on.
- Oh good, let's keep, I think
it's going really good guys.
- No, no, definitely.
- So far.
- I wouldn't think, I
wouldn't feel worried.
I think you're doing, great.
- I would completely
- thank you.
- You too Tom.
- It's like church.
- It's great right?
It's great right?
- Yeah.
- It's great.
(cheers and applause)
- You're having a
good time here right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- How often do you get to
hang out with the Workaholics
live and in person come on!
- This is true.
- Unbelievable.
- I mean if you guys go
to like a Jack in the Box
you'll probably see us
eating burgers or something.
- Yeah.
- We'll probably be
at Jack in the box.
- You can go there
but this is unique.
- Young lady what's
your question?
- Hi, hello.
- [Tom] Hello.
- I was wondering.
- [Adam] You were so scared
of your own voice right there.
(laughs)
Hi, uh, ah.
- I was wondering
how your real lives compare
to your characters lives?
- Oh they're like
exactly the same.
- Yeah.
- It's a reality show
you didn't know that?
- Yeah.
- It's apples and apples.
- I think we're pretty
similar to our characters.
I'm just as stupid.
- Yeah.
- I'm just as dumb in real life.
But like if we did everything
that we did on the show
we would 100% be dead people.
- Yeah.
- So.
- Life would have been
cut a little short.
- Hey kids don't do
everything you see on TV.
- Yeah.
- Talking to you little man.
- Yeah this dude.
Young blood.
- Stay in school.
- [Tom] What's the question sir?
- I was wondering if you
guys have ever thought
about doing a movie together,
because I mean, you've
had so much success
with the show.
- [Anders] With these guys?
- Yeah.
- Fuck yes.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, we're working on
tightening a script right now.
- Yeah.
- Tighten up that doggie.
- We're about ready
to get in on that.
- It's not a Workaholics movie.
(shouts from crowd)
- Ah dude, I would yup.
- Maybe movie number two, if
they allow us to make that.
- For Crossbows and Mustaches.
- We could do crossbows as a
movie that would be a dream.
- Yeah.
- It's big action comedy
starring the three of us,
it's not a
Workaholics movie but,
if you like Workaholics,
you're gonna like it.
We got cool like Seth
Rogen and Evan Goldsberg.
- Yeah, yeah,
- And Scott Rudin are
helping us produce it
so.
- Yeah.
- You guys see This Is The End?
It was really funny.
- It was good right?
- Super good right?
- Great movie, check it out.
- They knocked it
out of the park.
- I just really wanna be
in This Is The End two.
- Yeah,
- Right,
- So.
- Get like mutilated
somehow by an alien?
- Uh, yeah, no, it'll
be just like the premier
of This Is The End and the
actual Apocalypse happens.
- That's cool.
- That's fucking good.
- Its levels, it's levels so.
There's levels to this shit.
- That's layered.
- That's like twisted.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
Mmm.
- [Tom] What's your name sir?
- [Alex] My name is Alex.
- [Tom] Hi Alex.
- Woo!
- [Tom] Hey Alex,
you have a question?
- Sick name.
- [Tom] You have a question
for the Workaholics?
- I do, so I was going to ask,
so we obviously all
love tight butt hole.
- Yeah, we went over that.
- But I was hoping if you
could give us a sneak phrase
or sneak quote from
the next season.
- Sneak something.
- Sneak phrase.
- Awesomer.
- It might be just sneak phrase.
(audience laughs)
It might be, hey man quit
trying to do a sneak phrase.
- You just got it.
- Sneak Phrase.
- Trying to sneak
a phrase on me.
- That's I'm feeling that.
- Comedy Central let's get
those printed up on shirts.
- Sneak phrase.
- We're walking in here
trying to drop a sneak phrase.
(audience laughs)
- [Adam] You drop
some sneak phrases.
- I like that.
- Are you trying
to sneak phrase me?
- Are you coming at me
with a sneak phrase?
- Don't sneak phrase me
in front of my parents.
- Yeah.
- My mom's here.
- Sneak phrase it to me.
(audience laughs)
It's not even a different, it's
just different inflections,
sneak phrase it to me.
(audience laughs)
- No we can't do that.
(Workaholics theme plays)